baby tate's on the project yeah she's
fired i just met her in miami she's
amazing shout out to her uh she had uh
i asked her who was uh her all-time trap
artist and she did not include jeezy
geezy or ti crazy i was a little i was a
little old
dang she said scooter fire
she really atlanta girl no scooter is
[ __ ] incredible
gucci obviously of course what the migos
what
and
say ole miss i'll say you owe me a verse
i don't know why i can't think of the
guy's name make the trap say eh
we signed a gucci duma juice man oj the
juice man
where would you put like your if you had
we're talking about trap trap music
atlanta
hmm
i mean
of course like
t i got it shout out to jesus
it's t-i-g-z
yeah yeah in that order
in that order just because t.i trap
music that's a staple who's got more
classics
but i'm not doing that i'm not answering
it it's cheesy
i think it's cheesy
i think you got you got i'm playing the
fifth all right all right only because
random question would you take uh
tm 101 or the recession
didn't want easy
but the recession recession was amazing
it was good but i'm taking tn101 it just
reminded me of a time period in atlanta
100 a whole new wall party like just
some young [ __ ] all right so we got to
fill it out well you said uh
ti cheesy
still got guys out there like gucci
gotta say what just gotta say gucci
um
i don't go the little baby up there
already it's hard let's go baby
baby man oh god
i've never seen somebody improve so
drastically at rapping so fast
don't you agree like
he's
my last one oh nudie yeah shout out to
nudie
nudie's also someone who doesn't get
enough flowers nationally at least yeah
um
little baby though yeah you're a [ __ ]
mc's mc yeah hasn't it been crazy to see
just how impeccable he's gotten like at
this rapping [ __ ] nah just what he's
made for it's so it's so impressive
you could tell when he said somebody you
know what i'm saying you could tell this
is his calling because he went from like
being like really open and like yeah
gunna like helps me like help me start
to write and [ __ ] and like now he's like
top tier don't miss yeah he deserves it
though he did yeah he deserved it bro i
don't really like gifted so